Progress in AI can feel incremental
until you step back and think in terms
of weeks and months rather than just
days. So, this video won't just be about
the release then of GPT 4.1 in the last
48 hours or cleaning 2.0 or a sneak peek
at the next OpenAI model 03 or even
about Dolphin Gemma, the hopeful new
language model from Google. It will be
about all of this in the wider context
and how seven such stories contextualize
where we are in AI and what's happening.
I want to start with something super
practical just for those who don't care
much about the incremental advance in
intelligence and just want cool tools to
use. For those people in the last few
days, Clling have released Clling 2.0.
And here is a workflow that I recommend.
Generate an image with ChachiBT because
it has incredible text fidelity. Not
perfect, but really good. Now, you
shouldn't really explain a joke, but as
you can tell, the background image is
somewhat taking the piss out of OpenAI's
model names. Pro tip, if you have any
curse words, ChatgPT will generate that,
but Cling won't work with that within
the image. So, I had to use a version
without GPT WTF. Anyway, the only point
I wanted to make is that Cling 2.0 for
me is the state-of-the-art at generating
smooth realistic scenes. Of course, not
perfect with regard to physics. And yes,
I have compared it directly to V2 and
also to Sora video generations. And no,
I'm not going to belabor the point
because it's not perfect, but sometimes
incremental progress when you step back
can add up to something quite
significant. Speaking of which, of
course, in the last 48 hours, we got
GPT4.1 from OpenAI. That's their first
model that can process up to a million
tokens, or think of that as around
750,000 words. Aside from being a bit
less verbose than the notoriously
talkative Claude 3.7 Sonnet or the
famously geralus Gemini 2.5 Pro, I don't
actually think GPT 4.1 is that much of a
step forward. So, I'm not going to spend
a huge amount of time on it, but just a
few words on its background. GPT 4.1
like GPT 4.5 is not a reasoning model.
It doesn't output those long chains of
thought before giving you an answer.
That then begs the question of why
release 4.1 when we already have GPT40
and GPT 4.5 which are also non-reasoning
models. It seems like demand for GPT 4.5
wasn't as great as OpenAI hoped. And
that could be because of how expensive
GP 4.5 was or how great Gemini 2.5 Pro
is. So OpenAI wanted to release a
non-reasoning model that answers more
quickly that was better than GPT40 but
not as expensive as GPT 4.5. And for
those of you at the back with your hands
up, why do we even need non-reasoning
models when the reasoning models do so
well? If you can improve these quote
base models on software engineering,
then when reasoning is applied to those
better base models, you will get a
better end result. But there is a slight
marketing problem for OpenAI. If Google
can somehow serve reasoning models that
perform better for a lower price than
OpenAI can serve non-reasoning models.
Take ADA's Polyglot coding benchmark,
which is a popular and well- reggarded
benchmark. You don't have to remember
any of these numbers. Just focus on
relative performance with GP 4.1 getting
52% at a cost of around $10. If you bear
in mind those numbers, we can then
scroll up and see Gemini 2.5 Pro getting
73% correct at a cost of $6. On my own
benchmark, Simple Bench, you can see a
clustering effect now for those base
models, those non-reasoning models. GPT
4.1 gets 27% which is very similar to
Llama 4 Maverick, Clawude 3.5 Sonnet,
and the new DeepSeek V3. Worth noting
though that we could finally benchmark
Grock 3 because the API was released and
that scored 36.1% comparing directly to
the original GP 4.5 at around 34%. Now,
I know you guys are noticing Gemini 2.5
Pro way out in the lead, but more on
that in a moment. What about that 1
million token context window? Doesn't
that really stand out? Well, yes, except
Gemini 2.5 Pro also has a 1 million
token context window. And when you
sprinkle in a bunch of clues across a
long fiction story, as for this amazing
benchmark, you can see which models
actually pick up on those clues and
utilize that long context the best.
Piecing together plot narratives across
many diverse chapters. Well, as you can
possibly see if you zoom in, Gemini 2.5
Pro can do this even across novel
length, 100,000word length pieces of
fiction. On this benchmark, GBC 4.1
falls far behind, as does pretty much
every other model than Gemini 2.5 Pro.
So, when you see OpenAI t needle in a
haststack charts like this one, remember
they're selectively picking the
benchmarks that make their models look
the best. Llama 4, you may remember, did
a very similar thing. And of course,
don't get any of us started on LM Arena,
which can be gamed heavily and was by
Meta. Now, you might say that's a little
harsh given that OpenAI just open
sourced a brand new benchmark, an Eval
on Long Context called OpenAI MRCR. The
only problem is that we've already had a
benchmark like that for over a year from
Google and with this benchmark, we could
compare across model families. It turns
out that if you're in the lead, you're
much more inclined to compare your model
to other model families. Now, of course,
I am aware that by tonight or at least
within the next week, we are likely
getting 03 from OpenAI. According to the
information, that's the model that can
really help with science. It can connect
the dots between concepts from different
fields to suggest new types of
experiments involving anything from
nuclear fusion to pathogen detection.
This is according to people who have
tested the model. And apparently, we're
not just going to get 03, but 04 mini.
Now, as the title promised, I do have to
critically analyze this announcement
though, even before it actually happens.
First, obviously, it would have to be
extremely good to justify a $20,000 per
month price as the information reports.
Second, models can perform well in
benchmarks, but not actually understand
the real world or perform effectively
when conducting science. And yes, that
includes Gemini 2.5, as one researcher
recently found. Any of you following
SimpleBench or doing your own tests
probably saw this coming, but look what
happened when he created a benchmark on
manufacturing this simple brass part.
All models except Gemini 2.5 failed at
the first hurdle just because they had
horrible visual abilities. But even
Gemini 2.5 had terrible physical
reasoning. Its machining plans had
multiple critical errors that a beginner
machinist would spot. It could parrot
textbook terms but lacked practical
understanding. And that's Gemini 2.5.
Remember that AI co-scientist powered by
Gemini 2 that Google touted in February.
I'm not saying that Gemini 2.5 or 03
can't suggest interesting new research
directions. It's just they don't have
this mystical understanding of science
that no other human has. Not yet at
least. And I say not yet for two
reasons. One I'll give at the end of the
video and one here. models are
incrementally getting better even at
physical reasoning, spatial reasoning
type of questions. I haven't personally
tested 03, but I have analyzed a bunch
of its answers through someone I know.
No, they don't work at OpenAI. The model
does still make basic errors, but it's
the only one to get certain questions
right that I have never seen any other
model get right even once. That's pretty
much all I can say at this point without
a risk of getting sued, but it does back
up my incremental improvement point. Of
course, 03, especially on any high
setting, is likely to be slower and more
expensive than Gemini 2.5 Pro, but that
might not matter as much as you think,
especially if, in the words of Satia
Nadella and now Sam Alman from this week
that OpenAI is moving from being a model
company to being a product company. Chat
GPT is like a standard user. The model
capability is very smart. But we have to
build a great product, not just a great
model. And so there will be a lot of
people with great models and we will try
to build the best product. The focus on
this channel is much more on the
state-of-the-art in model intelligence
rather than in product features. But I
have noticed a trend. More and more
product features are now being copied or
shared across all the different model
providers. Anthropic with the Claude
series now has web search and is soon
going to have a voice assistant just
like OpenAI. And now Anthropic have
joined the deep research party with
their own research mode. That comes
after Gemini updating their own deep
research tool with Gemini 2.5 Pro.
Meaning that, and it's hardly
surprising, the Gemini tool is now
arguably the best one. I recently
switched over from defaulting to
OpenAI's deep research to Gemini's one
simply because it's faster and on
average slightly better. I'm not as keen
on how even for a simple query, it
outputs this massive volume of text, but
still its accuracy is slightly higher
for me. Of course, that means it's
getting slightly harder to justify
paying for the $200 pro tier for OpenAI,
but let's see what they release in the
next week. Speaking of deep research, if
you want to see how all LLMs lie when
they're trying to justify their reasons
for an answer, do check out the latest
video on my Patreon. One somewhat
amusing test I gave was to see which
deep research would make up a report on
an African author that I entirely made
up from my imagination. One deep
research tool does spectacularly well,
the other not so much. If you are a
little overwhelmed with all the product
offerings, Safe Super Intelligence from
Ilas Suskava has got your back. They
offer precisely zero products. That has
not stopped them being now valued at $32
billion. Apparently, this is not a
madeup figure. People are giving them
billions of dollars. This time, $2
billion at that valuation. That's what
they value the company at. I have
precisely zero extra details to give
you. It's just the obvious question.
What on earth are they up to? One
product that is here right now is the
sponsors of today's video, Emergent
Mind, where you can see which AI papers
have caught fire online. Now, while I
might have the time to go off and then
read those papers, what you can do if
you wish is use Gemini 2.5 Pro to
summarize those papers. Or say you're
just interested in a topic like reward
hacking, you can search for it and get a
summary of all the relevant papers from
Gemini 2.5 Pro. And I actually know the
creator of Emergent Mind and I asked for
this feature where you could directly
then click on the PDF and boom, here it
is. As I've said before, I also love the
social section at the bottom where you
can see the social media reaction to a
certain paper. And I'm on the pro tier,
which is free by the way for students
who are currently enrolled in college or
university. The links, as ever, will be
in the description for
emergentmind.com. Now, as with many of
you, my attention was caught by dolphin
Gemma from Google. How Google AI is
quote helping decode dolphin
communication. That is a grand title and
it got millions of views on social
media. But when you dig in, I don't
know, there's just a bit less than meets
the eye. Don't get me wrong, I think
it's incredible that we are trying to do
this and I am so enthusiastic about it.
I absolutely love animals. It's just
that if you analyze any of the hype
headlines you've seen across YouTube and
Twitter, it would make it sound like we
already have a model that can do that.
The announcement though was more about
progress. How they had accumulated an
incredible data set and how they had an
ultimate goal of doing certain things.
See down here, the ultimate goal of this
research is to understand the structure
and potential meaning within the natural
sounds of dolphins, seeking patterns and
rules that might indicate language. If
you watch the accompanying video, one of
the researchers says, quote, "We don't
know if they have words." Obviously, I
and pretty much everyone watching hopes
they have a language because that would
be insane to be able to decode it. It's
just don't be fooled by any hype
headlines. We don't actually know if
they have a coherent language. We know
certain sound types correlate with
certain behaviors like whistles that
seem like they are unique names. Special
sounds as many animals have that they
release during fights or buzzing during
courtship. But that's different from
more abstract rules as they say that
might indicate language. Again, they're
looking for potential meanings in the
sounds coming from dolphins using a 400
million parameter model that can fit on
a Pixel 9 phone. They then go on to tout
one obvious benefit of fitting on a
phone, which is their goal to quote
speak dolphin. Of course, once you've
decoded certain sounds, you can get your
phone to emit those sounds and
essentially communicate with a dolphin.
That would be incredible. It would of
course establish a simpler shared
vocabulary. That is the hope of
researchers that naturally curious
dolphins will learn to mimic the
whistles to request certain items for
example. Again, absolutely incredible
research and I really do hope they
succeed. I would be their number one
fan, but I just wanted to give you a
sense of where we actually are
currently. By the way, I suspect
dolphins do have a proto language, so
I'm fingers crossed for this mission.
Now, I could have ended the video there,
but as I outlined at the beginning, I
wanted to step back and give you guys a
sense of context of where we are. You
may have gathered from various media
reports over the last few years that we
are compute constrained, that the only
thing limiting progress is a lack of,
for example, Nvidia GPUs. Even that, of
course, would be a simplification
because Google announced a seventh
generation TPU not relying on Nvidia.
But even if you've just embibed that
general narrative that it's all about
compute, well, this video from OpenAI
pre-training GBC 4.5 might have a few
answers for you. The truth is it's
actually much more about data
constraints now rather than compute
constraints. It's very interesting
because I think up until this rough
point in time, like if you look even
through GP4, we were largely just in a
computed environment. Um so that was
kind of where all the research was going
into but now we're you know in a very
different kind of regime. Um starting
with 4.5 for some uh aspects of the data
where we are much more data bound. Um so
there's not not a lot more excitement
about this research. It is a crazy
update that I don't think the world is
really groed yet. I should pick a
different one that the world has
understood yet. Uh that we're no longer
computed on the best models we can
produce. That's just like that was so
the world we lived in for so long. And
what's the most useful kind of data?
Evaluations or benchmarks. The chief
product officer at OpenAI explained it
well this week. He made a kind of a
comment along these same lines around
Ebells that uh that AI is almost like
capped in how amazing it can be by the
how good we are at Ebells. Does that
resonate? Any more thoughts along those
lines? These I mean these models are are
they're intelligences and intelligence
is so fundamentally multi-dimensional.
So, you can talk about a model being
amazing at competitive coding, which may
not be the same as that model being
great at front-end coding or back-end
coding or taking a whole bunch of code
that's written in Cobalt and turning it
into Python, you know, like and that's
just within the software engineering
world. Still, most of the world's data,
knowledge, process is is not public,
right? It's behind the walls of
companies or governments or other
things. And same way if you were going
to join a company you would spend your
first two weeks onboarding. You'd be
learning the company specific processes.
You'd get access to company specific
data. It's you can teach these the
models are smart enough you can teach
them anything but they need to have the
the sort of the raw data uh to to learn
from. And so there's a there's a sense
in which yeah I think the future is
really going to be incredibly smart
broadbased models tailored with company
specific or use case specific data so
that they perform really well on company
specific or use case specific things
you're going to measure that with custom
evals. And so you know what I what I was
referring to is just like these models
are really smart. You need to still
teach them things if the data is not in
their training set. And there's a huge
amount of use cases that are not going
to be in their training set because
they're relevant to one industry or one
company. That's why OpenAI want to work
with anyone they can with their OpenAI
pioneer program to get domain specific
evals. Having niche evaluations for your
models doesn't just help you extract the
good data from the bad and improve the
data efficiency of your model. It also
helps you identify the best new data to
improve your model. If that new data
contains information or you can think of
it as functions or programs that help
models perform better during
reinforcement learning, then it will be
prioritized. And that is why to sum up
among many other reasons I think Google
has taken the lead and may even have an
enduring lead. I'm not saying the new 03
won't pipp it on a few benchmarks. I'm
talking about a long-term trend over the
next year or two. Google can source
almost unlimited data. Think Google
search, Android, Chrome, Gmail, Google
Maps, YouTube, Whimo, self-driving, even
Calico life extension. And to wrap
things up where we started, remember the
lack of performance sometimes in simple
bench or on that broth manufacturing
benchmark? Well, just a week ago or so,
Google announced geospatial reasoning,
one of their first attempts to integrate
Gemini with a bunch of these spatial
reasoning tools. I'll let their one
minute promo video speak for itself.
From maps and trends to weather, floods,
and wildfires, Google has studied the
geospatial world for decades. And we've
made that information accessible through
AI models and realtime services. But
synthesizing across these models and
combining your data with ours can be
challenging and expensive. That's why
we're introducing geospatial reasoning.
You can now bring your data and models
together with Google's geospatial tools
for easier analysis using Gemini's
reasoning
ability. Gemini plans and enacts a
custom program, searching over data and
gathering inferences from multiple
models to unlock powerful
insights, all through a simple
conversational interface.
Geospatial reasoning can be a critical
tool for advancing public
[Music]
health, climate
resilience, commercial
[Music]
applications, and more. Google taking
what could be a permanent lead must be a
bitter decadel long sting for Musk and
Alolman in particular. I'm going to end
with a 45se secondond extract from a
recent documentary I put on Patreon
about how OpenAI was founded a decade
ago almost to the month to stop Google
creating AGI. Leaked emails from a later
lawsuit between Musk and Alolman
revealed a May email exchange about
stopping Google. And here it is. been
thinking a lot about whether it's
possible to stop humanity from
developing AI. To stop humanity from
developing AI, this is Sam Orman in an
email to Musk. I think the answer is
almost definitely not. If it's going to
happen anyway, it seems like it would be
good for someone other than Google to do
it first. Any thoughts on whether it
would be good for Y Combinator to start
a Manhattan project for AI? My sense is
we could get many of the top 50 to work
on it and we could structure it so that
the tech belongs to the world via some
sort of nonprofit. Thank you so much for
watching to the end. I can't wait for
this OpenAI researcher to add O4 Mini to
this long whiteboard list.